la responsabilité c'est celle de
garantir l'indépendance et j'allais dire
l'existence
d'une institution qui a plus d'un siècle
qu'est l'association des maires de
france qui a été créée comme françois
l'a rappelé avec sa home éloquence non
pas légendaire mets traditionnels qui a
été créé pour préserver les libertés
locales et l'association des maires de
france le président est bien de le
rappeler avec lui aussi beaucoup de
pertinence n'est forte que de son
indépendance et son indépendance est le
fruit de sa pluralité est le fruit de sa
représentativité et c'est dans cet
esprit là que françois baroin jacques
pélissard pour citer mes deux préférés
président avait des formidables
certainement avant ont incarné
l'association des maires de france et
c'est l'enjeu aujourd'hui que nous
devons affronter ce que nous assistons à
une tentative
d'opa de l'association des maires de
france l'une des dernières institutions
indépendantes sur le champ politique en
france aujourd'hui par la macro ni
quelles que soient les nuances du gris
la macro ni qui s'expriment et qui sont
en compétition en espérant être
majoritaire dans une future majorité on
va essayer leur éviter ça mais c'est pas
l'objet aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est
pas c'est toujours notre objectif si je
vais en parler d'ailleurs un petit peu
donc là dessus
c'est pourquoi les démarches et gérard
lâchez le c'est françois baroin le sosie
christian aussi parce qu'on sait lui
beaucoup au téléphone jusqu'au bout je
suis allé très très loin pour parvenir à
éviter au maire d'avoir cette
configuration déplaisante de deux listes
qui ne serait pas en positif donc quand
j'ai vu que en fait tout était prétexte
pour chercher un conflit et que les
communes ont besoin d'une armée forte et
indépendante nous aurons nous avons
besoin d'une à mf qui aide sur le plan
logistique les communes face à ces
fameux appel à projets il n'a mêmes qui
travaillent avec le parlement et
heureusement que le sénat n'est pas hors
sol contrairement malheureusement la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale qui
depuis la fin du cumul
produit des lois totalement déconnectée
des réalités du terrain eh bien nous
avons besoin d'une élève qui travaillent
de façon proactive en amont mais aussi
en évaluation des textes législatifs et
bien sûr un accompagnement de leur
élaboration et c'est cela que nous
portons aussi pour les prochaines années
nous avons besoin d'une mf parce que
c'est un combat physique proactive pour
la décentralisation cela a été dit façon
extrêmement percutante et pertinente oui
nous devons remettre la subsidiarité au
coeur du redressement du pays et les
mêmes peuvent rapporter cette voix aussi
oui cela résonne avec nos convictions
profondes ici à nerfs et bien c'est au
coeur de nos enjeux c'est d'arriver à
apporter à nouveau de l'efficacité de la
simplicité est donc de la responsabilité
donc du civisme
c'est je crois le coeur de
problématiques et ce combat là on doit
le mener à la mf on doit le mener à la
présidentielle et ça sera plus facile
après le congrès pas celui des maires
celui de notre parti et on doit le mener
bien sûr aux législatives ensuite c'est
ce qui nous motive c'est une vraie
vision de la france une vision de la
france riche non pas de ces territoires
pardonnez moi mais moi même j'utilise
parfois plus résumé je veux corriger de
son territoire de son terroir de son
terrain de ses habitants de sa réalité
de son histoire
combat de la nfc dans cette ligne là que
nous l'inscrivons il sera perdu si nous
ne menons pas il sera gagnée avec vous
merci
[Applaudissements]